let's begin this morning with a very
important topic rising violence against
asian americans the latest incident
reportedly involves japanese-american
actress karen fukuhara you might
recognize her as kamiko mirashiro from
the amazon prime series the boys she's
also appeared in the movie suicide squad
well this week on instagram fukuhara
said she was walking to a cafe to get
coffee when a man struck her in the back
of the head she did not say where the
incident happened quote i know i got
lucky fukuhara noted she he could have
carried a weapon the shock has me
thinking about taking self-defense
classes but why is this something we as
victims have to think about fukuhara
says she posted to raise awareness and
that the attacks have to stop of course
the stop aapi group has tracked nearly
11 000 hate incidents against members of
the aapi community from march of 2020 to
december 2021. it is happening with
increasing irregularity
i know i have friends uh my wife is
asian american she there are people that
i know that are carrying pepper spray
now in new york city in an attempt to
defend themselves should something
happen people say people who look like
me are under attack it's so sad and
painful vlad that you consider yourself
lucky that you just got hit on the head
because it could have been so much worse
yeah and i don't think it's i don't
think it's the problem with the victims
it's not for them to do something it's
for all of us to do that's right so yes
it does and she got a lot of support
from
olivia munn who tweeted i'm so grateful
you're safe chase crawford who plays
with her on the boys f this person uh
hope you're okay this is awful um
i'm glad we're raising awareness on this
issue